this
is episode 5 of storycast 21
i'm jane secker in august 2010
a mine collapse and the subsequent
efforts to rescue
33 miners entombed underground
was watched by a worldwide audience of
nearly
1 billion this is trapped
the chile miners
i'm jonathan samuels i'm a sky news
presenter
[Music]
the san jose mine is right in the middle
of the atacama desert which is in
the north of chile and it's about an
hour's drive from the small city of
copayappa
[Applause]
we pulled up on october the 6th 2010.
what we saw was remarkable
there were hundreds of tents there were
camper vans
there was a great deal of industrial
machinery and i remember just hearing
the noise
of generators i could hear the noise of
the drills the constant banging and
thumping
with these 33 flags i remember up high
on a hill each flag representing a
different
miner and they would be flattering like
crazy
in the breeze the original mineshaft
zigzags for miles as it descends
700 meters the trapped men have taken
refuge in an emergency
so there was this constant hum of
activities everyone waited and wondered
about the fate of these guys
trapped for nine weeks half a mile
beneath our feet
[Music]
i arrived about a week before the end of
the story if you like
[Laughter]
if you can imagine the mine was a bit
like a corkscrew
because it was a series of zigzag roads
[Music]
trucks would drive up and down these
roads to bring
the copper and gold from the bottom
right up to the surface
and it was quite down deep near the
bottom of the mine
where these men were when one of the
tunnels
collapsed
[Music]
we were just doing some job and suddenly
just a huge huge amounts of rocks like a
really huge amount of rook
coming down
and we tried to run we said that that's
about it
one of the miners his name was edison
pena he was 34 years old
he was an electrician by trade and he'd
travel to
the san jose mine to find work and a
better life
it's impossible to get out there's no
way to get out because it's a wall
you know what i mean it's a huge exit
but it's a
big big wall of rocks
don't even a spider can get in
the rescue effort started immediately of
course
[Music]
they started drilling boreholes
desperately trying to search for
signs of life
we never know if it is going to drill in
in the place that we want to
we were scared we were scared because we
most most of the time we thought we were
going to die
everybody was laying down everybody was
just
not uh with not hope
and it was very difficult because it was
complete darkness
there was no light
so 17 days had passed two and a half
weeks and
i don't think many people expected any
sign of life
after all that time and then
a miracle happened from deep deep
underground the strains of chile's
national anthem
on august the 22nd suddenly
a drill broke through into their
underground
chamber
when i live i want to live when i just
want to live live my life be with my
friends
i want to just breathe the air i wanted
to i wanted to
be outside and just live you know
amazing is living
the trapped men have taken refuge in an
emergency area 600 meters down
they're linked to the surface by a
six-inch borehole
used to communicate and get supplies to
them plan a video cameras were sent down
that
tiny hole and we got those first
spooky images in black and white grainy
images
of the miners all grinning at the camera
putting their thumbs up waving
a pair of eyes shining through the dark
confirmation that they had indeed
survived
the focus now is on keeping them alive
food
and water uh medicine of course
rehydration tablets and the like that
could all be sent down
to them while the rescuers on the
surface scratch their heads and thought
great we found them
how the hell do we get them out more
than 2
000 feet above them their families watch
the video images
emotions must be very mixed there was a
lot of worry because this was a very old
mine
and if we go down all guns blazing to
pull them out with huge drills
then there's a real fear that we could
cause more collapses
drilling to get them out will probably
begin within a few days and this is what
they'll use
a massive drill being driven to the site
in northern chile
everyone knew that just one wrong move
could undo all the amazing work that had
been done so far
once in place it'll begin the long hard
work down
for nearly a kilometer to reach the men
it's thought a specifically designed
lift
can then bring each of them to the
surface one at a time
they looked at lots of different options
and in the end they decided the best one
was to just drill
straight down ending up alongside where
the men were and then pulling them out
individually
using a capsule it looks like something
that nasa might have built
and it has a name to match the phoenix
but this will be going
700 meters down when i heard of the plan
[Music]
i was optimistic so i started running
people said to me that they shouldn't be
running but i just
just need to do something and start
running because i wanted to say
this mine is not gonna put me down
we're gonna rise
so there was quite a lot of space down
there for the miners they weren't
completely squeezed into this tiny hole
they had about two kilometers of tunnel
and edison pena
was a fitness fanatic
so the weeks start to pass four weeks
five weeks six weeks
and edison spends a lot of his time
running up and down the mine tunnel
trying to keep fit
[Music]
born in the heat of the desert
edison was a big elvis fan
not only was he a fan but he was also a
bit of an impersonator
deprived of the love of a father
he'd sing elvis songs to keep the other
minors happy and get them all singing
along
as well and i think also he was even
doing the actions
i really think that god was happy
when i sing because when i sing
i knew that god was listening to me
i was singing because god want me to
[Music]
sing
[Music]
it's now october and the men have been
underground for more than two months
they've had that communication tunnel
but it was only the width of a coffee
cup
but what they needed was the rescue
tunnel that tunnel which was going to be
the width of
the capsule for the men to squeeze in
and be pulled up to the surface
and then on that day they were sat there
in the dark and they could hear the
drill getting closer
and closer and suddenly the tip broke
through
and one of them shouted we can see the
nose it's through
it's through
understandably those operating the drill
reveled in the moment
[Applause]
the relatives too were jubilant i know
there was
this madness above
because we heard these uh comedians and
politicians
but the only true person that i wanted
to see upstairs was my brother
my brother was one of the real person
about
not part of this festival this this
madness
[Music]
in the next few days rescue workers will
undertake one of the world's deepest
mine rescue attempts
the miners have been warned i remember
seeing plans for the capsules and
thinking
there's no way there is no way i would
be able to do this
the able will be brought out first to
make sure the capsule works
followed by the weak and the most able
obviously these guys are miners so
they're used to
uh working in pretty inhospitable places
but i think even for them
psychologically this was a big deal
getting into this cage
that you could barely fit in having the
door shut behind you
just giving your life to the people on
the surface
the journey could take anything from 15
minutes to one hour
the man in charge of the rescue
operation warns it can't be wrong the
only way out was this capsule
you're not able to move you have to be
quiet and you know you have to be quiet
you know why
because it's the only way and this this
thing
sounds like and you have to be quiet
and you know why because there's no
other way this is just the only way out
so you have to be quiet
there was definitely a moment when we
were all
desperately hoping that this was going
to work for all 33 men when i
saw some kids running around the camp
and their dad
was down there and remember a lot of
these men were young and they had young
families
and i remember looking at the kids
thinking god i hope your dad comes out
it is midnight here in chile at the san
jose
mine in the takama desert we are
watching
it's now october the 13th 2010
10 weeks since the mine had collapsed
and the drilling had stopped
and there was this almost hush across
the camp
because we knew the day had arrived and
everyone was
just silently praying and hoping for the
best outcome the young miner is now
inside the capsule five minutes 26 into
his journey to the surface
where everyone is waiting
i was i was not afraid
because i knew that in 12 minutes or
something
i'm gonna be out and i'm gonna eat the
world
like my like my dogs my my galilgo dogs
if you unleash a gal go dog he's gonna
run and i
and i felt like was a like a dog and i
want to
start running and eat the world
all we can watch is that wheel turning
as it holds the cable with the capsule
on the end of it
up to the surface the journey down often
as a
as a correspondence as a reporter on the
scene witnessing history you're sort of
slightly removed from the action and
from what's going on
president pierre waiting also on the
surface but for some reason this was
a completely different there's movement
now at the top of the tunnel
there seems to be some sort of activity
as they release the
the pulley i was just sat there watching
the monitor
gripped by it like a billion people were
around the world
15 minutes eight seconds like the
families were in their little camps like
all the rescuers were who were standing
watching as well suddenly for a moment
uh forgot i was there for work and was
completely caught up in the moment
[Applause]
[Music]
when i get out i i talked to god
and i said god here i am i get to give
me the signal
[Music]
i want to be tough and i want to say the
truth
i promise a lot of things
[Applause]
now i am something
now i am one of the 33 miners
[Music]
well that was the plan send the capsule
down with a rescuer bring up a miner
down 622 meters of narrow tunnel
the chilean mine rescue has to be
probably one of the most amazing stories
that i've ever covered in 25 years as a
journalist
following the rescue of the 33 men
chile's mining industry had a safety
overhaul
but edison pena and many of the miners
say they have
never been properly compensated for
safety breaches
that contributed to the collapse of the
san jose mine
and left them unable to work trapped
the chile miners was written and
produced by robert mulhern
for more information on this podcast go
to skynews.com
forward slash storycast 21.
next time after i got the bullet injury
i thought i would die
i could not tolerate the pain and
burning in my injured area
i did not know where i was going all the
people carrying me
only alan knows what was happening
[Music]